[Music]
hey folks welcome to the dark horse
podcast live stream number 120 something
123 123
123 that's that's a lot and you are oh i
am dr brett weinstein and watch this you
are dr heather hein indian rhymes with
flying we are here today your friendly
neighborhood evolutionary biologists
friendly neighborhood ever maybe not
your neighborhood but somebody's yeah
and maybe not friendly to you if you are
actively not making sense but there you
go all right yeah but these people they
make sense absolutely we're friendly to
them um
yeah so today we're going to talk a
little bit about elon's twitter play um
and uh creeping hospitalization as
predicted by the late great evolutionary
theorist w d hamilton
uh whether puberty blockers are actually
temporary and therefore harmless
and related to that why we are
tolerating porn
and uh and maybe other things if we get
to it yeah other things maybe maybe
other things if we get to them
but let us start with some
some logistics here
we we have some we have a lot of
craziness in our schedule upcoming and
uh we will and um soon hopefully there
will be a better way of communicating
such things so you can go and look and
see what's coming up but that's not that
is not happening yet
our next dark horse livestream is going
to be not this thursday but the
following thursday on april 28th
sometime in the afternoon probably
around 4 30 p.m pacific
after that we'll miss um the following
saturday as well will be back on
saturday may 7th and then away for a
couple more weeks before coming back to
you for nearly back-to-back episodes on
thursday may 26th
and then may 28th so it is thursday the
20th april 28th april 28th is the next
time we'll be coming to you
uh we got some good stuff coming um
in that time
and however we will actually be live
streaming to our patreon our patrons um
in the private q a before that so we
will be back on our private q a a week
from tomorrow sunday
[Music]
sunday april 24th
at 11 a.m pacific so and both of those
are uh going to be off the hook that is
on the schedule both of what uh those
streams the private one and the uh
public thursday
yeah there were a lot in the public list
so all of those
yes yes
but i was trying to be i was trying to
say something okay so next sunday if you
want to hear from us next weekend please
consider joining me at my patreon where
we have the dark horse uh private uh
live streams and um that too will be
improved in coming months but we're not
going to say anything more about that
just yet now if you want to riff on
something go for it no no i
remember the uh song by the band x your
phone's off the hook but you're not no
it's one of the great song titles of all
time and it's lost because we don't put
phones on hooks anymore but
you know
it is what it is i guess yeah
um it's kind of harsh isn't it your
phone's off the hook but you're
really to the point xxx did that well
yeah they did yeah they did yeah harsh
harsh but
fair it's clear yes
harsh but true
um
all right so
we are of course streaming on youtube
and honestly the chat is live on odyssey
you can ask questions for the q a to
follow this at
www.darkhorseadmissions.com
because our schedule is so odd coming up
there may be some of those non-saturday
episodes where we're not doing q and a's
but we are today uh and as always we
will start with a question from um the
people on our discord server uh you can
get access to that community uh which is
thriving and lively by joining either of
our patreons
and also brad has a couple of wonderful
conversations each month on his
so um
this last week on natural selections my
sub stack i posted uh i posted something
that i alluded to last week on darkhorse
about coming of age and
what it means in modern times and how
margaret mead understood it how many
years later michael moffett an
anthropologist at rutgers understood it
who was doing
kind of a participant observation
acting as an undergraduate even while he
was actually in
a tenured professor at rutgers in a in a
professional
non-non-awful way
and um i encourage you to go there and
then um so we're gonna be
hopefully um not on the internet for a
little while here uh but i have already
posted to to land um in subscribers
inboxes this tuesday this is free if you
want to join me at natural selections
some of the questions that we alluded to
i think last week as well where um not
yes actually this the next friday um is
earth day
and we not related to earth day but we
did a workshop uh in our evolution and
ecology across latitudes year-long
program which included a lot of domestic
field work and also an 11-week study
abroad through ecuador
and we basically asked students a whole
slew of questions many of which are
simple
once you know or once you have derived
the answers and some of which are so
complex that no one has the complete
answers yet but they are all questions
about the earth questions about the
seasons and the sun and the moon and the
biota and the hemispheres and the tides
and all of this and so i have um those
will those will for free subscribers um
half of those will land in your inbox um
to for natural selections on tuesday and
then i posted a little bit less than
half of them for paying subscribers for
wednesday yes they're the kind of
puzzles that make your brain last longer
exactly the kind of things even if you
know like
why are the phases of the moon what they
are
figuring out how to describe it right
yes it will reveal things about what you
don't know or things like uh you know if
the moon is full when does it rise that
kind of thing exactly and as i was
reminded actually looking over those
questions that we had given to our
students early in this year-long program
back in fall of 2015
that we specifically said
you should aim to be able to have an
understanding sufficient and a
communication
style sufficient such that a very smart
and curious sixth grader should be able
to understand you yes and um that is
that is an honorable goal you know when
when people
when you hear people talking
um about
about complex things or about things
that they tell you are complex and you
can find no way in sometimes it's
because you don't speak the language yet
and
you should be able to do some back and
forth in order to learn the language
that they are using
and sometimes too often it's because
they either haven't bothered to or they
actually have an interest in not
actually speaking in a way that you are
capable of understanding that other
people outside of their little tiny
intellectual tribe are capable of
understanding of course this is a this
is a form of gatekeeping this is a this
is a form of making sure that the people
with the credentials and the authorities
can sort of stand over lord over tower
over everyone else and thus make
decisions on our behalf and this is
anti-democratic it's anti-scientific
it's anti-humane
and uh we we of course at darkhorse are
exactly trying to do the opposite and we
did in our classrooms and we do in our
book hunter-gatherer's guide to the 21st
century it's dense sometimes it's tough
going sometimes but we try to make it
accessible because
accessibility is not a sign that you're
not doing important work in fact
failure to be accessible can be a sign
that you actually don't really
understand what you're doing yeah it's
actually also it's a great way to make
enemies um being accessible yes making
things perfectly clear right there's a
way in which most people aren't seeking
to make enemies so that it's not really
a selling point well you know it depends
you know
you you make your own choices in these
regards but um but yes it does it does
make enemies whether you like it or not
and you know the intelligent
six-year-old is uh is a is actually a
higher bar than you would think i mean
it's higher sixth grader sixth grader
six-year-old is a little tough
we did that with our kids sometimes but
of course
but that's not that's not what we
established but these uh but a kid a kid
is prone to hold you to uh a high
standard of clarity and they will find
things that you might elide you know in
your explanation things you're a little
vague on um that they uh they will force
you to uh
to describe that's right
um now we also
uh
while we are not uh live streaming
the following saturday at some point in
that general milieu there actually will
be a dark horse episode that that drops
you with a guest we won't say more about
it now but it should be uh it should be
excellent it has a little extra
complexity in the editing so i don't
want to promise a particular date but
there's there's one coming keep your eye
out okay um and i actually wanted to
give a shout out also as you were
mentioning discord um we were invited we
can't go but we have been invited to a
gathering there are apparently
gatherings that are happening our
discord people are arranging to meet in
person which is so cool and i ran into
somebody at the supermarket and they uh
they invited us so anyway there's
yes here in portland there's apparently
quite a community so and we actually we
had dinner with a couple of um
of people who we did not previously know
and i didn't ask in advance so i'm not
going to say anything more about them
but really extraordinary men and we were
we're just
we're very grateful um to so many of you
for um for your being here with us for
being grateful and for um in this case
um allowing us to learn from you as well
yep absolutely we should endeavor to
stay on their good side by the way
yeah
all right so
uh i guess uh without further ado we
have as usual uh three sponsors we do
not take uh sponsorships from products
that we cannot either personally vouch
for or have a particular personal
attachment to in some way so
you can be sure when we are when that
green perimeter is around the screen or
you hear that tone leading in and we are
actually reading ads
we actually do
speak on behalf of these sponsors all
right
all right
[Music]
our first sponsor this week is relief
band a product that can help with nausea
under
ancient circumstances nausea was
generally a useful signal that something
is off you had eaten something you
shouldn't have or were near something
emanating a bad smell itself a signal
that you should not get near it in
modernity we still need to track our
bodily sensitivities we should not
always choose to simply erase discomfort
like nausea whenever we feel it that
said some of modernity creates nausea
that does no good at all travel sickness
for instance can be agonizing and relief
would be lovely
enter relief band relief band is an
anti-nausea wristband that has been
clinically proven to relieve and prevent
nausea associated with motion sickness
anxiety migraines chemotherapy and more
relief band is 100 drug free and can be
used for as long as you need it
developed over 20 years ago it is the
only over-the-counter wearable device
that has been used in hospitals and
oncology clinics to treat nausea and
vomiting there are zero side effects
and now there's relief van sport which
is waterproof features interchangeable
bands and has extended battery life
we asked a friend to try it out here is
her testimonial
i used to have nausea on a nearly daily
basis for both from both anxiety and the
need to take regular medication relief
band relieves my nausea in less than
three minutes without the side effects i
was experiencing from anti-nausea
medication it has entirely changed my
life for the better
so if you've got nausea from anxiety or
car or sea sickness or something else
you cannot otherwise disable consider
relief band
relief band makes a great gift for any
time of year right now they've got an
exclusive offer just for darkhorse
listeners go to reliefband.com and use
the promo code darkhorse to receive 20
off plus free shipping and no question
questions asked thirty day money back
guarantee that's relief band
r-e-l-i-e-f-b-a-n-d
dot com and use promo code darkhorse for
20 off plus free shipping
our second ad this week our second
sponsor this week is for vivo barefoot
which regular listeners will be well
familiar with and increasingly when i
speak about it to
uh people i run into they know about
vevo vivos they know about bevo barefoot
these are shoes made for feet
most shoes are made for someone's idea
of what feet should be and be
constrained by and usually that someone
doesn't actually know feet or what they
can do
vehicle barefoot does no feet and these
shoes are a revelation
we love these shoes they are beyond
comfortable the tactile feedback from
the surfaces you're walking on is
amazing and they cause no pain at all
because there are no pressure points
forcing you your feet into odd positions
they're fantastic
our feet are the products of millions of
years of evolution hundreds of millions
of years billions of years depending on
how you count humans evolved to walk
move and run barefoot but modern shoes
that are overly cushioned and strangely
shaped have negatively impacted foot
function and are contributing to a
health crisis one in which people move
less than they might in part because
their shoes make their feet hurt
vivobarefoot shoes are designed wide to
provide natural stability thin to enable
you to feel more and flexible to help
you build your natural strength from the
ground up foot strength increases by 60
in a matter of months just by walking
around in them
the number of people wearing vivo
barefoots is growing it's an odd little
club easily recognize
easily recognizable because the shoes
are a little unusual looking
but once people start wearing these
shoes they don't seem to stop
go to vivobarefoot.com darkhorse to get
an exclusive offer of 20 off
additionally all new customers get a 100
day free trial so you can see if you
love them as much as we do that's
v-i-v-o-b-a-r-e-f-o-o-t dot com
dark
horse
our final sponsor uh for today is
brightmove
brightmove is modern recruiting software
otherwise known as an applicant tracking
system or ats if you're working a
staffing company or an rpo company or an
hr department you know exactly what an
ats is and if you're not using
brightmove you are missing out on the
opportunity to make more placements and
hires now this is a weird sponsor for us
it's a bit of an odd sponsor for us
since we don't have any reason to use
the product so why are we here talking
to you about it we are proud to be
sponsored by brightmove because it was
co-founded in 2004 by the current ceo
david webb
brett's experience with david was that
during unity 2020 he showed up to
volunteer took on a great deal of
responsibility and initiative in
planning and crafting the technical
aspects of the ranked choice voting
platform which was fantastic he's all
around a great guy and we have heard
from other people whom we now respect
that this product is terrific
so brightmove's co-founder is mission
aligned with darkhorse but what makes
brightmove the ats vendor for you
new software features are released every
three weeks the brightmove user base who
are recruiters and hiring executives are
the ones requesting new features tech
support is 100 us based and wins
customer services awards every year
recruiting analytics are unique and drag
and drop candidate cards to your hiring
workflow with our kanban style dashboard
their kanban style dashboard it's not
ours for rpo companies there are
additional features that no other
recruiting software can give you
they offer a single login for your
company and all customer instances a
global candidate pool to feed all
downstream hiring pipelines data
segregation for compliance and security
per rpo customer security roles for your
team and metrics reporting across all
customers brightmove includes ip
security and two-factor authentic
authentication on all of its offerings
to ensure peace of mind for business
owners and legal teams
and if you use a service like indeed or
a ziprecruiter brightmove can
supercharge your hiring by feeding all
new jobs to your internet job boards
then managing the influx of applicants
helping you filter and sort down to the
best list of people possible
you have to see for yourself why
brightmove is the best applicant
tracking system that's ats that you have
never heard of until now
visit brightmove.com darkhorse to
schedule a software demonstration today
if you become a customer you'll receive
one month of free service depending on
your company size and software package
that is a savings of between one and
three thousand dollars
visit brightmove.com darkhorse today
that's bri ght m-o-f-v-e i'm gonna do
that again b-r-i-g-h-t-m-o-v-e
dot com slash darkhorse
yeah actually it raises a pretty
interesting question which is how do you
know what to trust and
in the case of something where you can't
assess the product directly but you do
know that it's produced by somebody who
is a stellar human being who has
displayed high competence in a similar
realm competence and integrity
competently i have a high quality human
being that was wrapped in there um but
yeah anyway it's uh you know that's
exactly the kind of uh evidence that i
would take as a strong indicator if i
was looking for for some kind of product
i knew nothing about excellent so anyway
thanks david
all right uh you want to talk about what
you called elon's twitter play
yeah elon's twitter play so um there's
been a lot going on in the land of elon
and elon is a very uh interesting person
obviously he has gotten where he has
gotten through some very unusual
personal characteristics but in any case
in recent weeks he has become obviously
and publicly interested
in the state of twitter and potentially
doing something about it so he initially
took a substantial stake became its
largest
shareholder was
apparently headed to the board decided
not to get on the board which was
interesting there was a reason for that
i'm not sure he has said this exactly
but there was a limit
to how much
twitter
ownership he could have and be on the
board
and so he decided not to join the board
and then announced a plan to effectively
acquire twitter by buying up stock 43
billion dollars worth or something like
this
in any case
the reaction to this was
an all-out freak out by many many people
and
twitter itself responded by announcing
what's called a poison pill strategy and
the poison pill so taken from the idea
of somebody who doesn't want to be
captured would rather die than be
captured who might take a poison pill so
that they can't be tortured and give up
information the poison pill
is a business strategy they started uh
in the 80s there's several different
flavors but in this case basically it's
a
um a
plan in which the acquisition of stock
above some threshold will trigger
twitter to issue to
stockholders except the one in the
triggering position
stock at a greatly discounted price
thereby
driving up the cost to acquire it and
this is a very effective strategy
to uh prevent an acquisition i will
point out i don't know if you will
remember this but our good friend mike
brown former uh ceo of the nasdaq and
cfo of uh microsoft
uh is an accountant in microsoft's early
days yeah in microsoft's early days um
he is an accountant by training and he
once told us a story of an accounting
ploy used to prevent acquisitions went
by a very different name
which i remember to this day
which is a prickle ball and the idea was
a prickle ball was in a
financial structure that would cause the
swallowing corporation to gag and cough
up the corporation that had been
acquired somewhat slimier but otherwise
intact otherwise intact which actually
reminds me a little bit of uh
your um poison frogs that you studied uh
which also on occasion would be
swallowed by something that would then
think better of it and cough them up and
they would hop away i saw this precisely
once a boa took in a poison frog and uh
chewed on it for a while and
finally spit it back out and she went on
to become a successful mother the frog
did yeah which is an amazing it's
amazing to have seen that even once yeah
um extraordinary yeah especially if you
contract the animal and know that in
fact it goes on to reproduce thereby
telling a rather complete evolutionary
story luckily for me i had already
tattooed this particular frog so i did
not have to hassle it right then yes you
heard her correctly she tattooed the
frog yes yep um these were not gorgeous
tattoos no i never got like i mean
they're small frogs only have two layers
of two layers of skin to r3 so you have
to be really careful not to go that deep
and i didn't get to like mom with a
heart or anything they were alphanumeric
codes a1 b2 c3 etc yeah yeah well uh in
any case there's a lot we could we could
brickleball prickle but well you know
this is why these people tune in because
there's often a hidden evolutionary
connection and well and tattooing frogs
is the hidden evolutionary connection
yes to this um uh counter hostile
takeover
strategy
um anyway there are aspects so as i said
before i think there are multiple
different kinds of poison pills the
poison pill that
twitter deployed was this particular i
think it's the most standard poison pill
that um
is typically utilized
uh i i don't i don't know a ton about it
um
even though i'm uh you know that i'm
actually quite the investor
the investor yeah i'm i'm a
i'm a very good investor investor born
into the wrong portfolio that's pretty
much what i've concluded is that right
yes so you've invested in
well not the right stuff but i would
natively invest in the right stuff is
kind of the implication i see yeah i
don't i don't think i know what we're
talking about no um i don't know
often a cul-de-sac but
the point is
or the point that i wanted to make about
this is that the whole question about
why elon would acquire
twitter why he would seek to acquire it
he made very clear as he ran his poll on
twitter about whether or not we users
felt that
speech rights were properly protected
there
and in comments since he's made it quite
clear that his purpose isn't exactly
about the
financial potential of this investment
that he is actually
concerned about what is happening on
twitter
that affects what we do what in what is
clearly our new public square
which is a really interesting phenomenon
he you know the wealthiest person on
earth at the moment is in a position
actually to
move pieces on the chessboard of planet
earth that others simply couldn't
um
i wanted to connect it though to a
concept that we have talked about here
on dark horse many times
the tagline is zero is a special number
and
what we have meant by zero as a special
number is that there are lots of places
where you in order to engage in a
certain strategy need exactly zero
alternatives to be present so
the idea is if there was a
american
university for example that had declared
itself
immune to wokeness and
intent on simply continuing
the practice of teaching people to think
scientifically logically reasonably
teaching them about important facts of
history rather than indoctrinating them
into the belief that all white people
are racist uh or that the reason that
men out compete women athletically has
to do with the patriarchy or something
like this if a university declared
itself
interested in teaching in the way
universities used to attempt to teach it
would obviously be the place everybody
who wanted their children educated would
send them
and so the point is that's the obvious
strategy why why aren't there any and
the answer is there have to be none if
one university declared that strategy
and suddenly it was the new harvard
because everybody who had the ability to
choose where to go would go there so
they would not suffer the cost of paying
for their own indoctrination but would
actually enhance their minds then of
course that strategy would spread in
university after university would pick
up this strategy so there have to be
zero because if there was one it would
win right it does raise the question of
what kinds of uh
mechanisms are involved to keep it at
zero and i'm thinking with you know
within the university question
um and we will come back to to exactly
this question in uh
in our next couple of episodes actually
um but there are some you know there's
some new initiatives in higher ed that
look promising
and
uh until
i don't know
three five years ago the university of
chicago seemed to be holding strong and
saying you know we have the chicago
principles and we are not going to
succumb to the to the crazy basically
but they they stopped right so you know
what you know why did they given that it
seems like just at a fiscal level um the
existing
in this case elite university that said
not us come to here if you don't want
any of that
would just be drawing so many students
that they'd suddenly have resolved any
you know lingering economic issues that
they have right um so we can't you know
we can talk a little bit about all that
we've seen that has pressured
people into embracing uh idiotic
policies at the university or wherever
else but the basic point is there is so
much at stake right for the woke
revolution and the woke revolution
really is about certain people making a
move right they want to change where
they are and they may be justified in
wanting to change where they are in
civilization's hierarchy but they're
doing it by a legitimate means
and the point is there's so much at
stake for them in keeping the number of
universities that you can send your kid
to at zero that the point is you should
expect them to spend an ungodly amount
of effort or
resources to intimidate anybody who
attempts to evade this puzzle and create
the first you know
um you know
to put down a flag that declares
independence from from the movement so
the point is zero is a special number
because zero has to be the number if
there was a uh a newspaper that was
reporting reality right we'd all
subscribe right so there can't be a
newspaper that reports reality they all
have to suffer because zero's a special
number the corollary here though the
reason that uh i think this is important
in
the the current question about what elon
is up to and
and where we are is that zero is a
special number and the implication of
zero as a special number is that one is
an equally special number
so this is a bid to to get us a platform
that works now
is it possible that elon is not being
straightforward and he has some other
reason to want us to think that that's
what he's doing i guess but he has been
very clear and i don't see any real
reason to doubt him he's a guy who's
made enough resource and has
he's clearly having fun doing things
that a person might choose to want to do
choose to want to be remembered for and
this sort of fits with that ethos so
that's part of what angers people
frankly that he's having fun at it well
and i think it also scares them because
one of the things that works in favor of
those who wish to hold the number of
functional entities to zero is that in
general people who get control of one of
these things are subject to the same
incentives as everybody else and so it
doesn't mean that anybody's lost control
but in the case of somebody like elon
who can throw you know a vast sum at the
problem and still not
compromise his ability to do what he
wants in the world that's a frightening
prospect especially if what he wants to
do
is
um
protect
free speech rights because
think about all of the stuff i mean
given the last two years have been a
marvelous example of the importance of
twitter not being a free space right all
of the things that we have false
consensus on
right become very different if suddenly
you know you can uh speak openly on
twitter and nothing bad happens to you
yep
uh let me actually just
point out that um we're not gonna show
the video but
uh there's a video from morning joe this
week and you can show my screen briefly
if you want here uh in which the hosts
are talking about the bid and they are
not pleased again i'm not going to play
this through but one of the quotes the
the the salient quote from in here is
uh the female host whose name i've
forgotten says elon could actually
control what people think
that's our job
do they hear themselves well probably
not
and uh you know there's going to be a
lot of arm waving i'm sure to explain
explain this away but this is this is
precisely the problem right when you
when you reveal the man behind the
curtain and you see that they're doing
exactly the thing
um that they're claiming they're afraid
that someone else is going to do
and it seems more likely actually that
indeed that was a reveal of how many in
the mainstream media view themselves we
are here to tell you what to think
because you plebs are not smart enough
to understand yourselves um and if
someone else comes along and says i
actually
am interested in not letting you do that
it's as if the only possible
reason they can imagine for someone to
behave this way is with the same
um
ill intentions that they have
yeah exactly
uh now
what we think we are looking at here i
mean let's put it this way because we
don't know
what is he's actually up to this could
be
uh
very negative right in other words there
may be some as bad as twitter is maybe
it could be worse on the other hand it's
hard to imagine how it could be right
and when i say worse i don't just mean
unpleasant and nasty and slanted and all
of those things i mean actually
dangerous
and you know elon has alluded to this
but think about the things that have
been contentious on
twitter i mean for one it occurs to me
right now
articles of unity right
articles of unity was important
potentially even if it didn't stand an
important chance of succeeding in its
objective
the point was it was about hey we've got
a fundamental problem we've got two
broken political parties and they have
frozen everyone out we've got a duopoly
that we need to deal with and this is
becoming more lethal by
the decade and grassroots works and this
was unity was very grassroots
uh in large part
by spreading
via social networks until you know
yesterday effectively um through actual
social networks not not virtual social
networks
such that people became aware that there
were other people who were interested in
solving a problem that maybe they had a
little inkling of but couldn't quite put
their finger on or they knew very well
that there was a problem but didn't
think that anyone else saw it like them
so this is in part you know the the
tamping down of of projects like unity
um
the the importance of that as you just
said is not necessarily in the but you
know but we could have
won almost no one expected that there
was a real chance in that first
iteration
of you know unity going to the white
house
it would have been lovely but that
much of what it was doing was revealing
to as many people as possible we are out
here there are people who are thinking
carefully and consciously and
conscientiously and morally and
compassionately and rigorously and
logically about the same issues that all
of you care about
and if you feel like you haven't seen
anyone on the mainstream media about
whom you can say that in forever well
you're right and here we are
and um
in the context of the last election the
ability to say that was all the more
important because
the critical thing at the point that you
have two parties who
nominate people as old as joe biden and
donald trump
the question is well why would a party
not be able to nominate somebody who
is simply less likely
to be mentally compromised by age are
there no young people as competent as
though those two that seems really
unlikely and in fact if you look deeper
you look at highly competent people who
couldn't get through the primaries
because that is after all how the
duopoly maintains control for their real
constituents who are the the corrupters
of the system and so the ability to
simply have a place where you can speak
the obvious
or you can say look we have a corruption
problem this isn't new yes you're being
told you have no choice but to vote for
joe biden because donald trump is that
much of an existential threat to
humanity but you were also told that
about mitt romney and now you love him
so you know
the ability to say that is important
if elon were to succeed in saving one
platform then effectively he saves
social media because once there is one
platform in which you can say real
things how do the other platforms
continue their campaign of suppression
right because the fact is if you can't
say real things on facebook and you can
on twitter then people are going to
flood to twitter because in general this
is about people wanting to hear things
and the way to prevent them from hearing
them is to stamp them out so
they're just not sayable
which
i don't know what order we were planning
to go here but i would point out that
among the things that
twitter blocked the discussion of
was
hunter biden's
implication
that
his father's influence was for sale
right specifically with reference to
ukraine
our ability to talk about the
decrepitude of joe biden
was also
not permitted on twitter and so the
point is well
you can say
you know it was an election there was
chaos but the point is these things are
central to the issues of our current
moment right we had a right to discuss
it then because we are now suffering the
consequences of not having discussed it
right but don't you think it's good for
democracy that we aren't allowed to
critique our dear leader
well
i mean i can't believe that we are
placed in the position
that we are in and actually hold on yeah
obviously that was
sarcasm yeah but
the flip argument is also made back when
trump was president
it was it was it seemed to be the case
that many people thought it was bad for
democracy if you didn't critique
the the then person in the executive
branch which no one was imagining well
you know some people so people on some
people on the right maybe imagined trump
in the same sort of you know dear leader
role but the you know the dear leader
reference there with regard to biden is
you know this is this is not what
democracies do you know we have the
leaders that you cannot criticize uh
when when they make errors or when they
appear to not be up to the job
uh is
is indeed and this harkens back to what
we've been talking about in the last
couple of weeks
that was that's what happens under
totalitarianism not under democracy
uh exactly now i want to go back to an
error that i made during the election
which i have already acknowledged and
pointed out but it i'm reminded of it
this week um i said during the election
that i didn't think joe biden would be
sworn in i thought that there that this
was effectively a ploy that he was the
person who was going to
win the election and then there would be
a shuffle now the reason
that i thought that was that you know i
sometimes say no matter how cynical you
are you're still being naive
um
i was being naive
i thought there was no way that whatever
runs inside the democratic party i
thought there was no way that the dnc
would put us in the precarious position
in a world this dangerous in the middle
of a pandemic with as much at stake in
the world and as many hot spots that the
democratic party would put us in a
position of having a person who is
clearly losing their mental competence
at a rapid rate have that person be in
the role of the presidency
that's so mind-bogglingly dangerous that
i couldn't imagine that they were going
to let it happen and so i thought they
were going to do a swap with kamala
harris now i will say and i
can't believe that i'm going to say this
out loud
given what we are seeing with joe biden
i actually think as terrible a president
as i think kamala harris would be
i don't think we have any choice
i think the incompetence
and i i don't i know what you mean we
don't have any choice about what um
zach could you play the video of joe
biden from this week
so this uh this is one of many versions
of this i think this is the new york
post's
version
um
all right what we are going to see is at
the end of a speech here oh here we go
all right now that was an obviously
confused old man i take as i keep saying
i take no pleasure i i think he he's a
corrupt politician so some people
couldn't see that you want to describe
what he he is a confused man at the end
of a speech who
turns around
and has apparently forgotten what he's
supposed to do reaches out his hand to
shake the hand of someone who isn't
there so he shakes the hand with the air
and then he kind of stumbles around and
finally exits the stage
incoherently and you know if this
happened once
that'd be one thing but we have so many
instances of this sort of thing and it
was so evident during the election right
it's sad and it's dangerous
it couldn't be more dangerous it
couldn't be more dangerous as so what do
you mean by we don't have a choice i
don't know what choice you're talking
about an incompetent president has to be
replaced and the
chain of succession goes through kamala
harris okay and
i i don't want kamal harris as president
i think it's a terrifying prospect and
were she to become president i think the
other branches need to check her she
effectively needs to be
kept from exercising power and
her purpose therefore would be to be a
coherent person who can have somebody
call them up in the middle of the night
and say we have a problem we don't know
if nuclear this that or the other we
need a person whose mind is still
functioning to be able to answer a basic
question about what we do on behalf of
the american public and kamala harris is
in a better position to do that than joe
biden yeah if she's kept from acting as
an ideologue right and you know it's not
unprecedented that you would have
somebody step into the role and that
they basically would be there as a
a caretaker rather than as somebody put
in in place to to enact imaginative
policies or whatever but we are just we
it's hard to believe that in a pandemic
with a
a
war by vladimir putin in ukraine that we
could possibly tolerate a charade where
the person in power is clearly not
mentally capable of making difficult
decisions and therefore we don't really
know who is in power right we have an
unaccountable structure supposedly
protecting our interests
in an extremely dangerous moment of
history
how could the democratic party do that
to us
how how has how have they not taken joe
aside i mean
in his interest in the countries whose
interest is it in to keep him in in that
position at this moment and so this is
coming up here because
you view i believe although you haven't
said this here explicitly uh elon musk's
bid which could be cynical which could
be about something that we can't see but
it has the potential to be a patriotic
act well what i know is that during the
election when it was the right time to
talk about this when the answer is no
actually we can't elect joe biden
because even if you would have wanted
him in his younger more competent
state at this point he is not qualified
because he is not mentally there that
was evident during the election and the
point was twitter was not a place that
you could openly discuss it right
um so you know having been on the wrong
sides of those discussions trying to
point out hey we can't do this it's
unacceptable right this was taken as uh
support for trump
right
support for trump in a place where that
was considered unacceptable you have a
choice between a and b
i don't think so i want a choice beyond
a and b i don't like a and ah therefore
you're for b what i was about to tell
you that i like neither option nope
that's the choice if you don't like a
then you must like b we are forcing you
into not just choosing be but liking it
right and so i guess what i would say is
that this has been an interesting week
because we have um
the platform
or one of them that did so much work to
prevent the free exchange of obviously
important ideas like is this person
mentally competent enough to be elected
to this uh important office
right we have that question reopened by
elon musk's move but we also have
vindication even if i wasn't right that
he wasn't going to take office which
obviously i wasn't right but i was right
that his level of um
enfeeblement was significant enough that
that was an obvious question right it
has now become all the more obvious and
so we have to be able to discuss the
obvious in everything that is like the
public square we therefore need to go
from zero platforms which tolerate it
to one and i think what elon is gambling
on is that if we go to one it will go to
many
right once you have rescued one platform
people aren't going to stay where
they're infantilized on facebook or
instagram or wherever they're going to
go to the place where they can have
adult conversations about important
things and you know i'm i appreciate
whether he succeeds or fails i
appreciate that elon is trying to do
that with twitter and i really want to
see it succeed even if it's a disaster
it is essentially certain to be better
than it is it's hard to imagine how he
could make the situation more dangerous
well that actually i think um this idea
that
uh the duopoly in the at least the
american political system
um
which which which enforces winner takes
all and has seemed to trickle down if
you will into
uh enforcement at the individual level
of if you're not a then you are b and
not only are you b but you're going to
like it
this is a social construct this is
inherently a social construct there is
absolutely no reason for there to be two
and only two options in any political
sphere and you know every everyone above
the age of five knows that right there
are not just two options and so there is
this simultaneous i will say and here's
the segway
move
to force
social things which not only have fuzzy
borders but tend to have lots and lots
of instantiations and far more than two
categorical states into a binary
and thus make force people into sort of
blustering and getting flustered as they
say no no just because i don't like
biden doesn't mean i like trump that
sort of thing right
and simultaneously there is the opposite
thing going on
where there are some things in the
universe that are binary
and
we've walked through it lots of places
in our book many many places um but sex
is one of them in animals and in plants
and in and in other lineages
on this planet as well for reasons of
anti-sogomy of intermediate
sizes and shapes of gametes not being
stable we have males and females okay
and this binary
is being
overturned as if it is the social
construct at the same moment that we are
seeing
the binary imposed on a political sphere
where it has no place so there's there's
something very
bizarre and so backwards in both
directions they're like can you just
flip your your assumptions you know
reduce your assumptions as low as
possible but in this case the the entire
foundation that you're building both
your
sort of political understanding of the
world and your understanding of the
sexual world and therefore relationships
and everything else is backwards
completely backwards yeah it's
interesting it's almost the same
phenomenon that we saw uh with pandemic
policy where it's like at some point you
realize this isn't just nonsense it's
upside down right it's everything you
shouldn't be doing and so i guess what i
i like your point here quite a bit
if it's binary we're going to pretend
it's a continuum and if it's a continuum
we're going to insist that we describe
it in a binary term yeah and you know
i was also remind i've been watching
andrew yang
uh do what he's doing and i was reminded
you know we had
people who i am certain
are
competent
are young enough that they are not going
to lose their marbles in office who like
america right
that simple
those three things i mean you know
during unity we we laid out three
characteristics but this is even simpler
what what were the three against the
three the three characteristics just now
just now are uh
competent yeah
um young enough young enough that
they're not going to lose their marbles
and
they like america yeah patriots and
that's right so my feeling is if you
approach andrew yang right you say
andrew i got an idea for how we could
make stuff better you know here's what i
know hey he'd like to make stuff better
b he's going to ask good questions like
well
here are some downsides that might
accompany such a plan are they worth it
right
so
how i just don't understand
a universe in which you had somebody in
that office forget
political spectrum
party ideology i don't care just anybody
who can think and likes america and is
trying to do the right thing by it would
be preferable to somebody who's losing
their mind
is
corrupt and you know has higher
priorities and ideological um
you know
beholden to
a belief system that is not
we are all americans i am the president
of you the other americans and you know
we we have we have audience all over the
world um so i'm i'm not pretending that
everyone listening here is an american
but if you are uh the president of the
united states you need to have a kind of
patriotism you should not be a
nationalist and this is a distinction
that you have made very very often very
clearly um but you need to have an
appreciation of the country that you
hope to lead because uh if if that isn't
true there are a whole lot of us
um i i hope still a majority who think
that there is uh so much worth saving
here that if really what you're trying
to do is overturn you don't have any
place in the executive branch and i'm
not saying that that's what you know
biden is or harris or any of the rest
but the ideology underlying so much of
recent policy on the left
does look like that and when you look at
the you know when you go in deep on some
of the sort of founding principles not
of the democratic party but of places of
organizations like black lives matter
you find precisely that
well
i think what we also find is
and i don't like using these terms i
don't want it to be inflammatory but i i
think the point has to be made very
clear
if you leave a guy as compromised as joe
biden obviously is
in that
office during a moment like this in
history
you are telling us
that you don't love your country that
you are about something else and that
this is a means to an end for you
there's something machiavellian about a
party about the dnc about whatever it is
i mean we literally don't know who to
call
in an emergency right somebody might
know but we don't know we the public do
not know who is acting as our president
because our president obviously isn't he
couldn't
right and if he is that's even more
terrifying i guess i'm giving them the
benefit of the doubt and i'm imagining
there are other people making decisions
and they're just telling joe where to
stand and what to say but
it's gotta end it's gotta end somehow
somebody who loves america and is
capable of responding logically has to
be in that office even just for
emergencies
so the segway is to the actually binary
system oh yes of um of sex
which if you if you're done yep okay
um and we have here this week
not
working nope nope nope
please zack please take it off thank you
um
please don't put on my screen until i
say so um
all right so we have now you can now you
can show my screen
we have from fourth wave now which is a
reference to we need a fourth wave of
feminism because the third wave is
destroying us
the twitter account fourth wave now
which is terrific
has tweeted a video which we will show
you a little bit of
called puberty and transgender youth
from a
uh
an organization called amaze.org which
sells itself as a sex education
for for young people although when you
look deep into their site you find them
interested in
speaking to people younger than young
adults
as forthwave now says about this video
this is one of the vids that a new
jersey school district is considering
for fifth grade sex ed a um and then we
don't i won't read the
description here uh if i may have my
screen back
zach and i'm gonna ask you to show the
video in just a minute
um
boy what has happened
here we go
the youtube video in question
has a
actually if you can put it up zac i'm
gonna i just want to read the
description before
um yes please if you could put it up but
not play it yet so that i can show the
description
on the video
so i'm gonna read the description on the
video which you guys can't see yet um oh
there it is
uh everyone has a gender identity a
feeling or a sense of being male female
or somewhere in between sometimes
people's gender identity matches their
bodies and sometimes it does not someone
may be born with a penis and identify as
a girl or born with a vagina and
identify as a boy this person may have a
gender identity that is called
transgender what's important to remember
is that people deserve to express
themselves in ways that feels right for
them and to be respected no matter how
they identify look or dress
so we haven't even watched the video yet
and we're not going to watch the whole
thing even though it's short but
they begin with a premise and so many
so many of the arguments over in trans
activism land and
uh in
let's teach little children sex ed land
now are just
making claims that aren't true and they
see them as if they're the most obvious
thing in the world and they connect them
to things that are true
and it becomes hard for people who are
embattled or in any way just tired of it
and don't want it to be their main thing
to separate these things out so this
begins with everyone has a gender
identity
really
like that's a new concept that's a
social concept
gender as we have talked about in the
past we understand it to be the human
equivalent of what in non-human animals
is called sex role which is variously
the software to the hardware of sex or
in animals the behavioral representation
the behavioral manifestation of the sex
that you are
gender identity
is
frankly if it exists at all
is certainly not intrinsic and
fundamental and basic
it is regressive and um
you know usually it's going to be
frankly misogynistic if it's if it's
going against any particular sex at all
in that it basically says if you are
interested as a child in things
that traditionally have tended to be the
the wheelhouse the baileywick of the
other sex well then your gender identity
is the other sex
so if you're a mathy little girl your
gender identity is male
well this is sexist and regressive and
backwards and horrifying
all right um
two
two critiques of it one
the problem is it doesn't it basically
is um promoting
a
wish which may be transient
to a state of being
right in other words
you might want to be the other sex but
it doesn't mean that you are the other
sex identify as the other sex it could
be a legitimate want or it could be a
passing
phase but it doesn't really make any
sense to promote it you know as you
point out it's the it's the
either the behavioral manifestation or
the software of sex and so the point is
his gender is but gender identity is
like a step further in terms of
craziness
if you wish it then it is right and that
does if it's something internal which
right it doesn't it does not um add up
that you would promote it and the other
thing is
the need
to have this conversation right the you
may wish that you were the other
sex and not be and then essentially you
are has never been less because the
freedom to be
whatever you want to be to do in the
world what you want to do to fall in
love with who you want to fall in love
with that freedom is essentially total
at least in the west right or at least
it was becoming so and i i i feel
certain that this begins to undermine
and reverse many of those games so
before you keep going let's just show a
little bit of this video um zach i think
i told you how much of this video to
show okay
hi fish come here
oh you need a name
let's see
wait a second
what gender are you
a person who is transgender is someone
whose internal sense of their gender
being a boy girl or something else
doesn't match their physical body
people who feel this way sometimes feel
anxious when they begin to reach puberty
and their body starts to change in ways
that don't match their internal sense of
their gender
these feelings are totally normal
if you feel you want more time to
explore how you feel about your gender
before your body starts to change
it's important to talk with a parent
counselor therapist or doctor about the
feelings you have regarding your gender
after some discussion in counseling you
may be referred to an endocrinologist
endocrinologists specialize in hormones
and they are the most likely to
prescribe puberty blockers for someone
who wants them
puberty blockers are medications that
will stop your body from changing they
are usually given as an injection or an
implant
they block the production of hormones to
stop or delay the physical changes of
puberty
the effects of the medication are only
temporary so if a person stops using
puberty blockers the physical changes of
puberty will begin again
whether
so
the effects of the medication are only
temporary so if a person stops using
puberty blockers the physical changes of
puberty will begin again
this is a claim with no connection to
reality
and put that together with the claim
that was made on the banner but not
spoken in the video so for those just
listening
there was a banner across the top near
the end of what we just showed you that
said unfortunately not all health
insurance covers the cost of puberty
blockers
we are
experimenting
with children
those children experimented on will
never be the same
some of them will be okay
many of them will not
and they will have
every right
to come asking
of the adults of all of us
what it is that we were doing
what it is how it is that we allowed
giant numbers of children
to be
halted in their development
pretending that you can do that with
complex physiological anatomical yes
endocrinological systems and that it
will all be fine that you can just say
stop for a while and then if i decide
i'm fine i'll go back to it and you do
that furthermore to a child
who is already feeling anxious
and confused and maybe hopeless and
maybe a lot of other things but no child
who's feeling awesome about things and
is going through a developmental period
in which things are going smoothly
decides actually i'm the other thing
so these are these are children
who
maybe for completely normal reasons and
maybe because they are in go undergoing
other trauma or they have other mental
health issues have decided that they
have found the solution or
maybe even worse that they don't even
know what the solution is but what is
being sold to them is if you aren't sure
here's what we're going to do for you
having done that to them they are
guaranteed not to be able to walk back
into a normal development or a normal
life ever again
yes it is a case in which we are
falling down on our most fundamental
responsibility to children right we are
supposed to
give signposts and beacons that lead
children into the
uh
state of being that is most likely to be
one in which they can be effective and
feel fulfilled and rewarded and
find companionship
and instead we are telling them things
that we know aren't true right there is
no reason that it should be true that
you can
start a puberty blocker and if you
change your mind stop the puberty
blocker and just pick up where you left
off
um yeah that was quite something
yeah so for those watching and listening
our lights just flickered hopefully we
can finish the podcast carry on that was
quite the uh
lightning strike i assume but anyway the
point is
you're talking about a
radical intervention into a complex
system
in which we already know
that it's not a stop it will start it
will
system we have the evidence of that how
bad it is we couldn't possibly have the
evidence we'll find out when hundreds of
thousands of people have had their
puberty stopped and restarted and
we see what the full effects are over
the course of a lifetime but it is
radically misinformative and then we are
also just even the way that video starts
right everybody has a gender identity
and sometimes people's gender identity
doesn't match their sex and the answer
is look kids part of what being a child
is
is getting enough experience and where
you can't get enough experience getting
enough information from people who have
seen a larger part of the world about
how common things are right so imagine a
child lying in bed looking at a shadow
in their room and imagining it might be
some terrifying thing right and the
adult's job is to come in and say nope
there aren't any terrifying things here
in fact in my whole life i've seen
seven things that are terrifying and
they were you know they were grizzly
bears in glacier national park or
whatever they were never in your bedroom
right they were never in your bedroom
the thing is that those things don't
exist and so when you tell a child
um those things aren't here they're not
under your bed they're not on the wall
they're not in the closet they're not in
the neighborhood walking the streets
right they're not
they don't necessarily get it right away
but the point is their experience begins
to match what you've told them and they
will over time become an adult who knows
that those things aren't there right
whereas if you tell them oh yes
having a gender identity that is out of
phase with your morphology is something
that happens to lots of people right you
are giving them the exact opposite of
information so that to the extent that
they have a stray thought that doesn't
feel like it fits somewhere they don't
gravitate to ah-ha this is the thing i
saw in that video right if i am a girl
who wants to have short hair i must have
i must be a boy inside right
this is i mean
at the moment i i've been
i've been flabbergasted and angry at
many aspects of this for a for a long
time now but the at the moment it's the
explicitly
anti-woman anti-female
sexist
misogynistic regressive part of it that
is just
that is just amazing because it is
coming
from the people who brought us the metoo
movement who brought us
um
who are supposedly the standard bearers
of feminism but it is this third wave
feminism which is regressive which i
have for many years called
uh you know faux feminism and which for
which we have fourth wave feminism you
know fourth wave now accounts and and
others um suggesting boy do we need a
fix boy do we need to get back to
thinking about you know why
how it is for instance that straight
couples can live together in you know in
love and harmony and
not try to make each other into the
other thing right right because men are
not women and women are not men and on
average
men do tend to for instance uh be better
at just style of things and females men
no women tend to be better at
detail styles of things and there are
some amazing brilliant women just an
amazing really brilliant men at details
but pretending that if we're going to
live together as equals in which we both
respect one another we have to be the
same thing
is backwards
and imagining that what you can do is
say oh well i'm actually good at some of
those things that have traditionally
been and maybe more likely to be in the
domain of men
maybe i'm a man
no no i'm not and neither is any other
woman who has ever been good at math or
sports or
you know anything of science like all of
these things that are so powerful and
what
crazy world would say
if you're interested in those things
you're actually a dude
i i can't believe we're having this
conversation in the 21st century
it's unbelievable it's crazy and the
fact is you know
the facts
they're plenty good enough yeah you know
what
there are trans people they are very
very rare the chances that you are one
are very low the fact is some trans
people may not have come out because
there was a lot of pressure not to do so
that was back in the day back in the day
that has become much less significant
if you think you might be trans you
ought to wait a whole bunch of time and
figure out if it clears up because it
does for most people and that's
certainly the simplest way to go about
it rather than doing some radical
medical experiment on yourself that will
probably leave you infertile and disrupt
who knows what other processes
at the same time right
there's nothing wrong with the facts
here the facts are conveyable
in the rare case where those facts are
salient they can be conveyed we don't
need to
pretend right it's just it's
preposterous
um
are we where we go we're going on this
because something uh
well you wanted to also talk a little
bit about um
pornography before we do that before we
do that i want to do one other thing
that just
yeah wow
more lightning that's not so common here
and it was just thunder we're hearing
well we're hearing the thunder
but i'm thinking it's the same
phenomenon what did you say producer
zach
it is it is
um
producer zach
is 18
now he had a birthday this week
our our firstborn is now a an adult by
in the eyes of the law yes we can
literally not tell him what to do
anymore we have to ask nicely and
you know let the chips fall where they
may
um
that's not a match for anything in our
family no no none of it is but um
so i wanted to
i had this uh incident on uh twitter i
think it may even have been yesterday
um there was a hashtag uh
game effectively people start these
things they start a hashtag
and um
people respond to it and
it trends and anyway you see what the is
there is there a game to it you said
kind of yeah the idea is so this one um
was stupid thing women stupid things
women do which is not the kind of
hashtag i would usually respond to but
in this case
um an amazingly good
evolutionary joke occurred to me it was
perfect in almost every regard but one
all right very very deep
um and
educational and the one way in which it
wasn't such a great joke is that i knew
nobody was going to get it but
i
that doesn't always stop you no no and
in this case it didn't i i i
what did you do well here's the thing
should i go look yeah you got you have
it zach
can't read it
uh so the hashtag is stupid things women
do and my response
is
meiosis
um which
now you know so here's the thing all
right making a joke that nobody's gonna
get isn't the best thing but not making
that joke and living the rest of my life
knowing that i failed to make it how was
i gonna do that see that's that's that's
a that's a frankly a male brand
condition right there how will i live
not having made the joke that no one was
going to get well anyway just fine it's
not gonna i'm pretty sure it's not gonna
get funny for my explaining it but i do
think so that people will get the next
such joke when somebody else has such a
great opportunity i think i should
because it was interesting what unfolded
right i don't know i don't know several
people corrected me and they were like
uh brett
men also do meiosis sure right of course
of course of course that happened
right so anyway god does he not know
does he oh my god um
so i here's the but i think you'll see
why this is relevant to this
conversation
you already kind of but um here's why
the joke is
hilariously funny if you're and
therefore what it means right yeah um so
meiosis is the process by which a
diploid individual that is a person who
has uh two versions of every chromosome
produces a sex cell that has only one
chromosome of each type and then two sex
cells from two different people get
together and they restore that diploid
state and then the zygote or two
different zebras
zebra well you weren't just talking
about humans right no oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah definitely this does apply to
zebras i should have said that thank you
all right sorry
but
okay here's that's what meiosis is right
so
somebody responded to me um
obviously males and females equally
engaging right right somebody responded
to me uh men also do meiosis and i
responded to them yes but what choice do
they have right which is really the key
to the joke because women do have a
choice now they will individually have a
choice but
here's the amazing strange
counterintuitive weird evolutionary
underpinnings of the whole
crazy state of affairs
is that females
could clone themselves
instead of going through meiosis and
they could produce an exact copy of
themselves and although that seems weird
to us in fact it has a huge evolutionary
benefit to it which is that if you
produce a clone of yourself
instead of dividing your genome in half
and only passing half of it onto each
offspring it is evolutionarily twice as
fit
so
there is a question about why given that
females
can double effectively double their
fitness by cloning themselves rather
than engaging in sexual reproduction as
these fancy lizards have done yeah zach
do you want to put up those fancy
lizards
my screen
yeah so these are whipped tail lizards
this is nemadoferous uniparents is the
species it's all female
they actually continue to have to engage
in pseudocopulatory behavior in order to
get their eggs to drop basically there's
some complicated endocrinological uh
explanation but they are
they are an asexual species which
descends from a
bisexual species which has males
but all you know females lay eggs that
are 100 related to them now they do
engage
they actually do engage in meiosis and
so um yeah it's complicated um but they
also occasionally
get uh
input from stray males and that sort of
keeps things interesting yeah so anyway
at some point we will go into the
details of that story and how it is the
exception that proves the rule but the
basic point is there is a mystery a big
evolutionary mystery it's not a little
one it's a giant one
why females who have the capacity
probably more easily than they do to
produce a sex cell and join it with some
half genome from somebody else and hope
that this brand new combination never
seen on earth before of genes is going
to function well that's a big deal their
immune system isn't going to respond
badly to it right that's a big gamble
whereas i've made it to reproductive age
my genome obviously works why don't i
just copy it 100 right that's liable to
be a much better bet so why do females
in
no animal species uh do this without
some and like we have to go back to the
whip tales the occasional
uh copulation with males but the point
is why given how much evolutionary
benefit comes from dispensing with males
entirely and simply cloning yourself why
is this not constantly being attempted
by females in every animal species right
so
and just uh
just to go back to you know the
distinction between the sexes being the
gametes that they produce
uh females producing large gametes that
are full of the cytoplasm that is going
to be needed to make a new life and um
and also fairly sessile fairly fairly
immobile and males producing small
gametes have been stripped of almost
everything but basically half a genome
and a motor and therefore being small
and zippy and they do the job of finding
and females do the job of bringing all
the stuff that's necessary except for
that half the genome that the males
bring
we are defined
um as
uh we have long since defined
that sex which brings the large immobile
gametes as the females and that sex
which brings the small zippy gamete says
the males and therefore there are no
all-male species because male gametes
can't produce um can't develop into
young because they don't have the
cytoplasm in the cell in the sperm or
the pollen required all right so now the
punch line of this whole discussion
is
that males and females aren't remotely
alike right it's not this whole
uh
contagious idea that we are the same and
it's arbitrary and all this is nonsense
in many ways
we are opposites and
the
the point is
females doing meiosis and therefore
condemning themselves to the phenomena
to having to interact with males in
order to produce offspring which puts
them in one of two conundrums right
females can either attempt to compel
males to participate in raising the
offspring so that they
are not costing themselves by raising
half a genome that isn't related to them
right or they can accept the cost of
raising a half a genome that isn't
theirs
which is a giant cost in evolutionary
terms that's the female predicament so
when this person responded yeah but
males engage in meiosis too it's like
yeah of course male is engaged in
meiosis but it's not a stupid thing they
do right it's a
screaming great deal because they can't
reproduce otherwise right the point is
females have a choice which they don't
take which is interesting right that's
why the joke was hilariously funny to me
i i think it's good actually yeah it's a
pretty good joke um for the
i don't know a few hundred people who
get it but anyway i thought i thought it
was it's instructive seeing that even
even something like this for people who
obviously know the term meiosis don't
necessarily spot the asymmetry between
male meiosis and female meiosis in terms
of whether it's you know an obviously
great idea or a paradox
right or um
you know inherently obligate
or
at some level not for mammals at this
point right but but facultative at least
if you go far back enough well another
way to put it is it is a choice but it's
a choice that is always a loser if you
make what seems like the better choice
and therefore selection has stopped
experimenting with it right the point is
and asexual species uh don't persist and
actually this um we will end up just
saying a little bit about wd hamilton at
the end here and um one of you know he
was
you know one one of the greatest uh
evolutionary theorists uh he died young
too young at like 63 in um in 2000
and uh what some of his great
contributions to evolutionary theory
involved the evolution of sex
and um specifically he and it was
marlene zuck right
who proposed the idea that this was
about invasion of parasite loads yep the
hamilton zoo hypothesis
all right i said one thing before we
move on from uh my hilariously funny to
a tiny number of people joke yeah um
which
what was it
right now i lost
[Applause]
it oh yes
another person commented and i feel
because they were not wrong that i do
not want to dismiss their observation
somebody commented that women do not do
meiosis that
meiosis is done the eggs are produced
before uh females are born which
technically is largely true not a
hundred percent true the jury's still
out on this one actually you know what i
got to stop saying that about science
because um you know it mixes the
scientific and the legal as if that's
fine and i've taken issue before where
it was a headline
said that some scientific result was
effectively like a legal standing so
it's not it's not the jury is still out
it's that um
reasonable scientists disagree about
what the evidence means
from it might even be drosophila like
some other species which seem to have
the ability to
continue to produce eggs into adulthood
and
it's not clear exactly what is true for
humans
all right so the jury has returned on
the question of whether it is all right
to say the jury is still out within
science and the jury has decided it is
not acceptable to say the jury is still
out within science that's certainly true
and the jury has now exploded in a puff
of smoke from from being too
reticulated
exactly um
but
nonetheless the point about when
uh meiosis is done in females is a fair
question
but i will just say that it is in some
sense the ancestral femaleness that has
decided to continue engaging in meiosis
despite the annoyance of having to deal
with men
and um that
so the joke still stands even if there
is that technical caveat
i rather enjoy it and i rest my case
continuing to enjoy uh continuing to
engage with men
yes and i'm very pleased that this
paradoxical as i find it
all right did you before we finish up
talking a little bit just a little bit
about wd hamilton want to say anything
about porn or do you want to save that i
could save that one okay
um
on the hazards of
right
okay which we which we also
give
just a couple page section to in our
book so you know the position that we
understand porn to be
bad for people is not is not one that we
are
producing today but one that you will
say a little bit more about in a future
episode
okay
uh wd hamilton
uh was as i've said one of the great
evolutionary theorists he had many many
contributions
he died at 63 after having gone to
africa
in search of a the closest living
relative of hiv and he was he was he was
looking at chimps and collecting chimp
poop
and he contracted at malaria
and
after many weeks in the hospital back in
the uk when after he'd come home he died
and at that point his collective papers
were being uh his scientific papers are
being collected in volumes so narrow
roads through gene land
in gene land
right
now forgotten that i was looking at it i
was looking at these i'm embarrassed
that i don't i was looking at them so
often um this week and i've now
forgotten which what the
um
the letter is there um and what the word
is there uh but they were being
collected so you can look it up and tell
me once you find it um
the first volume was already out i think
those are the papers through 1980 and
the second volume through maybe 91
something or maybe getting the dates
wrong
was in the editing mode at the point
that he went to africa and so for each
of these uh for each of these published
scientific papers he was writing a
preamble introductory essay and
sometimes the preamble introductory
essay was far longer than the paper that
it was then uh introducing
and then there was a third volume that
came out um you know obviously without
any of his input at all that that
completed the set so is it narrow roads
of narrow roads of gene land volumes one
two and three and the second volume
which focuses on the evolution of sex
he writes an essay introducing a paper
on um condition of sex called the
hospitals are coming
now i was not able uh to get my hands on
the book yet it's it's still on its way
to us
but i actually came to know to be
reminded of this by this you can show my
screen for a moment here zach
um this psychology today
blog christopher badcock phd writes
something called the imprinted brain and
i actually i came to find him i'm just
going to walk you through a little bit
here because he had written a piece that
i found a little bit um actually a lot
dismissive of margaret mead but it was
his understanding of um what her
informants had had done his reporting of
someone else's findings of what her
informants had done
that really helped clarify for me what
some of the arguments in the
anthropological literature were
something i talked about last week so i
went looking at some of his other stuff
and it's actually often quite good and
so he has this piece published march
20th 2021 so we're a year into coven at
this point called global medicalization
has come with selfish herd immunity and
you can give me my screen back here now
zach but i am going to
read
a um
two paragraphs i guess from wd
hamilton's essay the hospitals are
coming
which was published as an introduction
to one of his other
scientific papers and was published
after his untimely death w hamilton's
untimely death in 2000
but written in the late 90s so this is a
piece written in the late 90s over the
years of my working life w d hamilton
wrote i have been slowly developing a
paranoia about hospitals the growth of
hospital buildings and all the
infrastructure of clinics pharmacies the
increasing domination of our
universities by medical schools
associated with huge hospitals all over
the developed world the unending love
affair the public have or are brow
britain to have with medicine through
the tv screen plays on doctors and on
hospital life accelerant birthing by
cesarean section the indefinite increase
of pharmacies even in the third world
the accompanying increase of our
everyday pills that tumble from every
bathroom cabinet
all these matters combine to tell us how
we are heading
happy in our progress for the present
like children on a fairground roller
coaster prattling of the genetic casties
to come nope that says castles but it
looks like cassie's which isn't a word
i'll start that sentence again happy in
our progress for the present like
children on a fairground roller coaster
prattling of the genetic castles to come
we skim onward uninformed into the
bowels of a great planetary hospital of
the new millennium
my dread is even worse it concerns how
by the time our joyride ends we will
realize that we have come into the
concrete heaven of our tv dreams but
only at basement level
so that's
one
let me read the second paragraph
increase again from wd hamilton
written in the late 90s
increasingly electronic upper and admin
levels in my hospital would look after
us in much the same way as the genome of
the karyote of the eukaryote maintains a
remnant genome sufficient for the
purposes of the overarching
nuclear-ruled hole requires in the form
of its one-time bacterial allies now
going by names such as mitochondria and
chloroplasts
where the bacteria perhaps lured into
the eukaryote cells by chemical
temptations analogous to our hospital tv
dramas
where promises held out to them how
grand dramatic and safe life would be
once they are inside promises of how
wonderful would be the biochemical
machines they could play with and what
dizzying and expert communication they
would see flying by them on all sides
were they told how they would be born
aloft in moving palaces humble denizens
of soil and slime no longer nor even of
merely stationary stromatolites
there in the new palaces they would be
fed advised and costed by the wisest of
guides and companions chromosomes out of
nuclei
wow all this for free a millionaire's
life on a cruise ship and all for
nothing
so the offer to the symbiont may have
seemed at first
so he is arguing that the symbiont which
may not have gotten quite the deal it
was hoping for
may be seen as analogous to the world we
are being offered uh with the increasing
hospitalization but he further argues of
course
that our hospitals the promises of the
western medical system can't do what it
is promising
it's an odd argument because i agree
with him about the hospitals and all of
the things associated with him i don't
agree with him about the symbiotes about
um there being an analogy
i think they got a good deal yeah um and
yeah i do too yeah so
anyway yeah i mean i think it's almost
actually
it's so clear that they got a good deal
that it's almost a tautology
right because the fact is it's not like
their
uh
relatives now their ancestors
did not get to continue on
absent the uh
right so so partners yeah so let's talk
about um briefly because we're we're
going along here um what the distinction
is
because uh you know because it's it's
not you know he and he doesn't say it
isn't like us but he says you know maybe
maybe this is like that
um so
in what way uh do do you see
uh the increasing hospitalization
uh
that's
hospitalization is the wrong word
because that's already a word in use but
um the increasing medicalization yeah of
human health as clearly being an offer
as if an offer by a would-be symbiont
that is one that we should be uh denying
refusing um i think my
uh concern about it is that the hospital
is part is a in large part
a parasite and to the extent it is not a
parasite it is a [ __ ]
because
it is not paying sufficient heed to the
downsides it will give you a pill that
may indeed have a positive effect on
whatever your condition is and it will
fail to measure all of the downsides
that you will experience in other words
if you measure the effect of this pill
on that condition you may see a
reduction in pathogenicity but if you
measured all cause mortality
mysteriously the person might die
early right and the point is until you
get to the all-cause mortality measure
you don't know that actually you came
out ahead for doing away with your
disease and you don't know
about the collateral damage of for
example prescribing antibiotics and
creating superbugs that wouldn't
otherwise exist and are much harder to
get rid of and so you solved the problem
the short term and you created a problem
in the long term right well i mean one
of the obvious distinctions uh to my
mind is that uh before two things were
in where symbios were in
uh
mandatory symbiotic relationship with
one another they both existed right they
they both had the ability to exist and
persist right and they may well have if
the if the symbiotic relationship has
itself persisted
that that is presumably better for both
of them but
when you're talking about humans being
medicalized by being sort of ever pushed
towards greater medicalization that
thing that is medicalization that is
hospitals that is pharmaceuticals that
is whatever it is
doesn't exist outside of humans so we
are we are being invited nate forced in
many cases to accept as a potential
symbiote if you will something which we
ourselves created which cannot exist
without us and which does not have the
inside of the complexity to to do our to
do our bidding especially if we imagine
that we are subservient to it right now
i would argue another way to put that is
that
at best
a hospital is a necessary evil
and the problem is that the route from
necessary evil to
uh
self-elaborating parasite is a very
short road and especially when you have
a profit driven
entity the point is the perverse
incentive incentives make it all but
certain that it will make this
transition and the point is the cost
will be to your health right it doesn't
mean that the hospital isn't something
you should be tremendously grateful for
at the point that you've been in an
accident and you're you know internally
bleeding and there's somebody there who
knows what to do about it right you
should be tremendously grateful but the
point is
to have that thing that there is
somebody who knows how to save me from
my internal hemorrhage
uh transmuted into this gigantic
conglomerate that will cause you to make
faustian bargains you don't even know
you're making and which further would
have you believe that you unto yourself
have no ability to heal yourself right
right exactly and you know when we talk
about this in our book even simple
things like i broke my arm am i better
off going to my doctor or avoiding my
doctor right
you know and at the risk of having the
usual things befall us
there is a question about vaccines right
there's a long schedule of vaccines that
we give to very young children who are
still involved in development and the
point is i'm not saying vaccines are bad
in fact i think they are fantastic in
some cases and in some cases they are by
far our best approach to numerous
diseases but that doesn't mean that
inherently vaccine is the right tool for
every disease and it doesn't mean that
there aren't important costs and so
really the question is is this one
justified do the cost benefits and
unknowns add up to this one being
something that i should uh you know
accept for my child for example yeah no
i mean it's a category error and it's
the the intentional i think in some
cases abuse of the category uh to
confuse people has worked it's like well
vaccine is an amazing concept and some
vaccines are are brought into the world
and are amazing therefore
the the arg the implicit part of the
argument goes as it squirrels away
underground um if you critique any
vaccine your your anti-vaxx and this is
like saying i like dinner
because dinner nourishes me
and now it's nine in the morning and you
say i need some nourishment you're gonna
need dinner dinner but it's not nope
you're gonna need dinner because dinner
is the thing
actually
i feel like this is a category problem
again and this is that would be one with
you know no ramifications that matter at
all but indeed it's like saying um
also i like dinner oh you're saying all
dinner is good and if you're not saying
all dinner is good therefore you're
anti-dinner you're you're an anti
actually i've had bad dinners yeah and
that doesn't mean i don't like dinner
right right um and so it is this way
with all of it and of course
um if you're going to have a prayer of
making the right choices in a landscape
in which you have a tremendous number of
medical things that you could accept or
reject if you were going to make good
choices a you would want an
expert working on your behalf you would
want a doctor and you would want that
doctor informed by a system that did not
have perverse incentives in it yes and
the point is you know
our system is so riddled with perverse
incentives that why you think you're
getting anything like information in the
first place is not clear right that's
right it's it's a it's a system so
broken it's guaranteed to fail as it
does repeatedly
indeed
well have we arrived i think we haven't
i think we've arrived and um the sun has
come out ish right now it
yeah
and our our cat here was watching
uh intently out the window actually went
fairfax uh went to the edge and i
thought i was concerned maybe he was
seeing a coyote out there it was a bunch
of deer he was watching deer and he has
he was not able to tell how far away
they were and so he had this thought of
but those tastes really good i bet i
could catch me one of those he was
having a delusion of grandeur yeah yes
exactly
exactly um all right so
we for those of you uh who are listening
and uh won't be hearing the q a
we will be
on next again on
thursday april 28th
we'll be missing next saturday but we'll
be back middle of the following week
and for those of you who
are interested in the q a if i can find
it again we'll be we'll be back in about
15 minutes on odyssey on youtube
you can uh ask questions for that q a
and we'll get to as many of them as we
can in about an hour um
we won't get to all of them we'll get to
many of them at
www.darkhorseadmissions.com
if you have logistical questions uh like
i have a thing i want to send them and
it's nice
you can you can ask darkhorsemoderator
gmail.com where you might send that
again we will be having a private q a
live stream uh in eight days sooner than
we'll be back on the the dark horse
platform uh which you can access by
joining my patreon
and
[Music]
until we see you next be good to the
ones you love eat good food
and get outside be well everyone
[Music]